[Music]
make sure nothing happens
we play by the book oh we're gonna play
by the book
okay
[Music]
they say hatchet uses the skinning knife
to erase the identity of his victims
abby you're a hell of an analyst but
chasing ghosts
it is not gonna change what happened
i need to be the one asking questions
captain pass for five minutes along with
the prisoner my hands are tied that is
the world's most dangerous man
no one knows more about him than i do
are you the operative known as hatchet
something's not right
we have gunfire
personnel code rex
i need to know everything there's no
sign of him
oh my god
what's going on
someone's releasing the detainees jesus
locking us down
count down
to what if we can't restore calm the
next hour they send a drone to wipe us
out
he's tying up loose ends shh
gonna tell us what really
you
happened
have no idea
dude
i'm not gonna hide
it's us through that
it was a mistake
to assign you to this case abby
time's ready
i got one rule stay alive
you